i realized quite early in my career that
to excel
i need to upskilled regularly
and since then i've been doing
certifications to support my current job
roles
my name is bashar i'm currently working
in saudi arabia
17 years i recently did my activity for
managing professional certification
and due to that i got a job
in a company with a salary hike
currently i'm preparing for msp
practitioner certification
and my future plan is to prepare for it
master certification
i've achieved so far 16 certifications
which include
msp foundation pmp article 4 managing
professional
and iso ic 20 000 practitioner to name a
few
to pursue itil certifications i needed a
blend of instructor-based and self-paced
learning
i did my research and found out that
simplylearn was providing a similar
model
another added advantage was simplylearn
provided access to the course content
even after course completion
and i could revise it before my final
exam
i took two courses from simply learn
ikel4
mpt and msp my learning experience was
very good as simply learn offers
easy to understand material with courses
after every module and practice exams to
check your knowledge
instructor word certified and
knowledgeable the trainings
were well paced with sufficient time and
i also enjoyed the communication with
the instructors
the certifications helped me to switch
to a new job with a salary hike
as itel v4 is recently released there
are handful likely v4 managing
professionals in the market in this part
of the world
my employer also acknowledged that i am
certified
people recognize me due to my domain
knowledge certifications and experience
which i gained
by applying these skills and
certifications
certifications have helped me get a lot
of confidence
and they gave me the drive wish i had in
my career